hello and welcome to lesson one in this
lesson we will discuss connecting the
Android devices wirelessly by the end of
this lesson you'll be able to define the
Android wireless api's explain the steps
involved in network service discovery
describe the process of p2p connections
with available Wi-Fi networks and
describe the steps involved in setting
up Wi-Fi p2p service publishing and
discovery in this module we will learn
about the Android wireless api's these
API is enable communication between the
Android devices that are connected to
the same local network and they also
enable communication between devices
that are not connected to the network
but are present at sufficient proximity
to each other network service discovery
NSD enables an application to publish a
network service or seek out a network
device providing the network service
with which it can communicate NSD
enables a wide range of applications
such as sharing files between devices
playing games with users in the same
room receiving images from an NST
enabled webcam connected to the same
network remotely logging into a machine
on the same network most network api
methods are asynchronous listeners are
generally registered to handle responses
this means that an API call returns
immediately without waiting for response
but passes a listener object an Android
system uses these listener interfaces to
pass the response to the application
note that all network operations involve
unpredictable delays and hence should
not be performed on the main thread
several methods are available in android
such as background operations and helper
threads
now let's discuss network service
discovery which involves the following
steps registering a service on the
network if our application is a provider
of the service discovering services
available on the network so that our
application can check if it can
communicate with the service provider
connecting to a service on the network
to start communication unregistering the
service before application closes so
that no other devices can see the
service for the application to use
network services the application should
declare the appropriate permission in
its manifest file in case of NSD service
discovery it is Android permission
internet registering the service is
required only if our application
provides a service this has two steps
one is creating a registration listener
object and other parameters and the
other is making an asynchronous API call
to register service the first step is to
create a registration listener object
that handles the registration event
callbacks NSD API uses the callbacks in
this interface to inform the application
about the success or failure or
registration or unregister ation of
events the service name is a string
which identifies the service
applications on other devices detect our
service by using this name for example
simply chat is a service name that
provides a chat service this name must
be unique on the network service type is
the one which specifies a protocol and
transport layer the application uses for
example HTTP underscore t CP
specifies that the application uses HTTP
protocol over TCP transport layer port
number identifies a port for each
address and protocol through which the
devices can communicate after
establishing a connection discovery
protocols should be used for connection
we use domain name service based
discovery international assigned number
authority IAA has published a list of
standard protocols and port numbers if
you intend to use a new service type it
is recommended that you reserve a
service type and port number with ia na
for demo purpose we will obtain an
available port on the device a
registration listener must implement the
following callback methods a reference
to the NSD service info object is passed
to all these callbacks in addition to
other parameters wherever necessary let
us talk about each callback method on
service registered is called when the
service is successfully registered on
the network on registration failed is
called when a failure occurs during
service registration an error code is
passed to indicate the exact error on
service unregistered is called when the
service is unregistered successfully an
application that provides a service must
unregister before closing on
unregistered failed is called when some
error occurs while unregistering the
service an error code is passed to
indicate the exact error to register our
service we get a reference to the system
service object of type context NSD
underscore service then we build a NSD
service info object for our simply chat
service which uses HTTP protocol over
tcp transport layer NSD manager dot
register service is called with
parameters service info object the
discovery protocol in this case domain
name service based discovery and the
registration listener let's talk about
how we can discover NSC services
available on the network the process of
discovering is very similar to that of
registering here again there are two
steps creating a discovery listener
object and other parameters and making
an asynchronous API to call discover
service first we have to create a
discovery listener object that handles
discovery event callbacks the NSC API
uses the methods in this interface to
inform our application when the
discovery is started when it fails and
when the services are found or lost lost
means is no longer available service
type specifies a protocol and transport
layer to look for discovery protocol to
use and we use domain name service based
discovery the discovery listener must
implement the following callback methods
on discovery started is called when the
discovery is started successfully on
service found is called when a service
is found and passes the service info
object corresponding to the found
service in this step it is a good
practice to check if the application
discovered its own network service or if
it is providing one if a service we are
looking for is discovered we can connect
to it but before connecting we must
determine the connection information for
that service by calling resolve service
open bracket close bracket API on
service lost is called when a service it
was previously found is no longer
available on discovery stopped is called
before stopping the discovery on start
discovery failed is called when the
discovery fails and provides the error
code that indicates the reason for
failure
on start discovery failed is called when
the stop discovery fails and provides
the error code that indicates the reason
for failure this step which is resolving
a service resolves the service that was
discovered in the previous step once
resolved our application receives the IP
address and the port number which is
required to make a connection to the
device providing the service to resolve
a service create a resolve listener
object that handles a resolve event
callbacks and SD API uses the methods in
this interface to inform our application
when the service resolve operation
succeeded or failed the resolve listener
must implement the following callback
methods on resolve failed is called when
the service resolve operation fails it
provides an error code to indicate the
reason for failure on service resolved
is called once the service is resolved
our application receives detailed
service information including an IP
address and port number using which the
application can establish network
connection to the service after
successfully resolving the service
information our application can connect
to the service using the Android Network
api's let's now discuss the importance
of unregistering a service if our
application provides an NSC service it
is important to close it before the
application is closed
unregistering will help other
applications from seeing the service is
still available in trying to connect
also the service discovery must be
stopped when the parent activity is
paused and it must be restarted when the
activity is resumed our application
should override appropriate life cycle
methods of the activity to start and
stop the service broadcast and discovery
as appropriate for example we could call
register or discover api's from
activities on resume callback similarly
unregister and stop discovery from
ondestroy callback
p2p is an acronym for peer-to-peer the
Wi-Fi p2p ap is enable applications to
connect to the nearby devices without
the need for devices to be connected to
a network or access points applications
running on a device can find other
devices nearby and begin connection and
start communicating using Android Wi-Fi
p2p ap is android Wi-Fi p2p AP is
conformed to Wi-Fi direct certification
the range of Wi-Fi p2p is larger than
that of the range of the Bluetooth range
following steps are involved in setting
up a Wi-Fi p2p connection between two
devices set up appropriate application
permissions set up broadcast receiver
and peer-to-peer manager initiate peer
discovery filter the list of peers
connect to appear disconnect peer
connection let us discuss each step in
the subsequent screens we need to
declare appropriate permissions in the
applications manifest XML file for our
application to use Wi-Fi p2p ap is the
following permissions are required
Android a permission dot access
underscore Wi-Fi underscore state
Android not permission dot change
underscore Wi-Fi underscore state
Android dot permission dot internet
although p2p does not require an
internet connection it still uses Java
sockets which require internet
permission to use Wi-Fi p2p we need to
listen for broadcast intents to tell our
application when certain events have
occurred in our application instantiate
an intent filter and activities on
create callback method and set it to
listen for the following Wi-Fi
underscore p2p underscore state
underscore changed underscore action
indicates whether Wi-Fi p2p is enabled
or disabled Wi-Fi underscore p2p
underscore peers underscore changed
underscore action indicates that the
available peer list has changed Wi-Fi
underscore p2p underscore connection
underscore changed underscore action
indicates the state of Wi-Fi p2p
connective
has changed Wi-Fi underscore p2p
underscore this underscore device
underscore changed underscore action
indicates this devices configuration
details have changed get an instance of
Wi-Fi p2p manager by calling get system
service and passing context Wi-Fi
underscore p2p underscore service and
initializing the p2p manager the
initialized call returns a Wi-Fi channel
object that we use to discover peer
devices create the broadcast receiver
class that listens and handles the Wi-Fi
p2p state changes in the broadcast
receivers on receive Open bracket close
bracket method handle each of the above
Wi-Fi p2p state change cases register
the broadcast receiver and intent filter
when the activity is active that is in
the activities on resume open bracket
close bracket callback method initiating
peer discovery to start searching for
peer devices nearby called p2p managers
discover peers and manager dot discover
peers open bracket em channel p2p
manager action listener closed bracket
semicolon M channel is a Wi-Fi channel
object received when you initialized the
peer-to-peer manager p2p manager action
listener is the listener that implements
methods using which the Android system
tells our application if the peer
discovery was successful or failed Wi-Fi
p2p manager action listener object
implements the following callback
methods on success open bracket close
bracket is called to indicate the
application that peer discovery started
successfully on failure is called to
indicate the application that peer
discovery failed with an error code that
indicates the reason for failure after
we invoke the discovered peers open
bracket close bracket API call any
change in the peers is notified to our
application via intent with action Wi-Fi
underscore p2p underscore peers
underscore changed underscore action
application should register a peer list
listener object which implements the
following callbacks public void on peers
available Wi-Fi p2p device list peer
list is called when a list of peers is
discovered by the system we can iterate
over the list and decide whom to connect
with note that on peers available
returns all the peers that are available
now including the ones that were
discovered in the previous call if our
application is managing a list of peers
flush out our existing list and create a
new one
the last step in establishing a p2p
connection is selecting a peer and
initiating connection from the list of
peers received via on pairs available
callback method choose a peer create a
Wi-Fi p2p config object and call connect
from p2p manager object we get the
device address from the Wi-Fi p2p device
object Wi-Fi Protected setup is set to
push button configuration PBC we pass
the action listener object to the
connect method which implements
callbacks to notify the connection
result following your callbacks of
action listener interface onsuccess is
called when connection to the device is
successful the broadcast receiver we
created earlier will receive an intent
with action Wi-Fi underscore p2p
underscore connection underscore changed
underscore action when the connection is
successful on failure is called when the
connection attempt fails with an error
code that indicates the reason for
failure
earlier in this lesson we learned how to
broadcast network services discover
connect and communicate with devices
offering known services between devices
that were connected to a network or
access point
however Wi-Fi p2p service discovery
allows us to publish services and
discover services of nearby devices
directly without the need to connect to
an Access Point steps involved in Wi-Fi
p2p service discovery are quite similar
to those in network service discovery
following steps are involved in setting
up Wi-Fi p2p service publishing and
discovery set up appropriate application
permissions create a local service and
register it if your application is
providing service discover nearby
devices that offer Wi-Fi p2p services
connect to a peer device and begin
communication let's look at the steps in
the subsequent screens as you are
familiar by now following in the
permissions required Android permission
change underscore Wi-Fi underscore state
Android dot permission internet although
p2p does not require internet connection
it still uses Java sockets which require
internet permission create a local
service and register it if our
application is providing service create
a Wi-Fi p2p service info object populate
it with information about your service
in the current example we create a hash
map of parameters that we use to create
Wi-Fi p2p service info object a hash map
is a collection of key-value object
pairs that the discovering device will
receive the receiving application is
expected to know the keys and extract
values to determine the exact service
offered Wi-Fi p2p DNS ST service info
represents Wi-Fi p2p or Wi-Fi direct
service info class which is used to
broadcast p2p services the first
parameter to new instance is the name of
the service instance in this case it is
underscore simply p2p the second
parameter is a protocol name dot
transport layer the last parameter is
the hash map of key value pairs
and manager is an instance of Wi-Fi p2p
manager by calling get system service in
passing context dot Wi-Fi underscore p2p
underscore service and initialize the
p2p manager M channel is an object
returned by the Wi-Fi p2p manager
initialize call action listener is a
Wi-Fi p2p manager action listener object
that implements the following callback
methods onsuccess open bracket close
bracket is called to indicate the
application that peer discovery started
successfully on failure is called to
indicate the application that peer
discovery failed with an error code that
indicates the reason for failure
discover nearby devices that offer Wi-Fi
p2p services setup listeners to receive
service response and service records
broadcast by service providers dns SD
service response listener implements
following callbacks on dns SD service
available is called with the actual
description in connection information
dns SD text record listener implements
following callbacks on dns SD text
record available is called with hash map
of the service published by p2p service
publisher that we learned earlier along
with the service hash map
device info structure results will
passed the receiving application can
maintain a list of available devices and
services offered by them this can be
presented to the user via a user
interface to select a service to
establish connection call add service
request to start receiving service
responses to service response listener
call discover services to start
receiving service records to text record
listener m channel is the channel object
returned by Wi-Fi p2p manager initialize
call action listener is the Wi-Fi p2p
manager action listener object that
implements following callback methods on
success open bracket closed bracket is
called to indicate the application that
peer discovery started successfully on
failure is called to indicate the
application that peer discovery failed
with an error code that indicates the
reason for failure
the last step in establishing a p2p
connection is to select a peer and
initiate connection from the list of
peers choose a peer create a Wi-Fi p2p
config object and call connect from the
p2p manager object this is similar to
the Wi-Fi p2p connection which we
discussed earlier after connection is
established devices can communicate
using an own protocol such as sending
print request to printer let us
summarize the topics covered in this
lesson in this lesson we define the
Android wireless API s for wireless
connections we discussed how to discover
the network service we explain the steps
to register the service we explain the
steps in resolving a service on the
network we listed the key points in
unregistering a service we describe the
p2p connections with Wi-Fi connection
setup finally we describe the steps
involved in setting up Wi-Fi p2p service
publishing and discovery this concludes
the lesson on connecting devices
wirelessly
you